that's the problem that i would have
never do it in new york
no man i've never done it we've never
done it there you know what's
interesting about me being here today i
was thinking about this on the way up is
the last time because you guys just
publicly announced your breakup yeah the
last time i was here was when history
hyenas had just broken up
oh yeah wow
right yeah it's a breakup thing
and it's interesting because
i know it's interesting yeah because i
just was like oh wow like how like
poetic
now because remember when i came in
remember when i came in remember yeah
what what what did you put on
team y'all yeah oh whoa
[Laughter]
yo it's the same shirt
it's the signature
the whites have beat the asians once
again
just like world war ii
[Laughter]
this is my favorite day of any podcast
i've ever done
that is so funny thank you for that
because i did i not wear the team jana
shirt i didn't huh no you didn't you did
not i didn't only bob i didn't
only bobby thank you for that he's gonna
need a second to recover
any thoughts on why uh team kalila
um
really the only thought of truthfully is
doing because i know you guys broke up
that sad i suck the only reason i did is
because he put on the team yeah
it'd be funny to put on team kalila then
team because you know i just thought
it'd be well you would be team kalila no
no no no no yeah in real life you know
my team right oh 100 yeah
yeah no hundred people you guys you both
stick together come on that's like like
so that's a brotherhood
no that's what it is yeah but this see
like something like this doing this just
[ __ ] on having fun i love how comics
heal where like some other podcast might
be like
that's offensive i'm gonna sue you
i have no idea what you're talking about
but i like it we're doing comedy here we
do comedy this is the show i know we're
doing the show
coming in hot today i think we don't
edit [ __ ] today wow that's yeah
[ __ ] it
put that down
you know what but you know what
what i wanted to tell people though is
because i've talked to a lot of like um
podcasts going i'm getting a lot of hate
oh and i'm getting a lot of this and
that and it's like what they don't
understand is is that it's still money
in your pocket or the worst thing that
someone can say about you online right
is them thinking about you yeah once
they're thinking about you in one way or
another it's money in your [ __ ]
pocket yeah thank god you'd rather from
a troll